this is a gigantic search and rescue
effort more than 16 000 rescue Personnel
in Turkey alone because it's a gigantic
search area I want to show you some of
the extent of that we'll start in Turkey
in Mirage and show you what's been
happening now this is near the epicenter
of it and we've seen some of the scenes
of destructions but we'll also see how
the search and rescue is operating
because on a lot of it on the face of it
it seems like it can be on a quite ad
hoc basis because it's so hard to get to
people we have seen Emergency Services
here but they are sort of picking
through it
um that is similar to other places and
again just to talk about the Aleppo in
Syria is a long long way away from the
epicenter but it was still really badly
damaged in this and we can see again
some of the search and rescue tactics
happening we're going to talk about this
in here we'll just take you through it
again look at this Devastation so we
have this it does again look sort of
impromptu bear in mind that uh Digger
we'll just go a bit forward so we can
show you the whole scene and really
understand what's going on so you even
though this looks like there may not be
quite the full monty in terms of it what
we do have is we have a digger here
another Digger there and what they're
doing is they're not getting in on the
middle instead you have the people here
so that means they can pick through by
hand look for people they may be locals
who know the area the diggers not
getting involved because they don't want
to do damage thyro but just in case
there are people inside now there are
other parts which have better equipment
and that enables a bit more of a
response this is also in Syria and
opposition held area where the white
helmets operate and you can see uh just
here actually or just put that out for
you just in case you can't make it out
that is a big concrete cutter and that
really changes what search and rescue
teams can do we'll just roll it through
this and you'll see what happens in this
video we'll take you through and you can
see
it being used here we go there so that
means they can just do a lot more than
those people we saw in the first video
in terms of other capabilities that is a
big bit of Kit it is handheld
um I want to show you what we've got
here another really challenging recipe
you've got a generator coming up here
but we're less interested in the
generator than what they're going to
attach to it and we'll just bring that
forward a slightly for you
this is a bit of care a bit of hydraulic
kit just coming in here if you just
watch that come down and those are
basically huge uh it's a combination
tool which comprise and Norco also bite
into things so as we go into this really
challenging I mean look how tight that
is look how tough those conditions are
but even in this very very small space
you can get that sort of equipment in it
so we just look at the end of this video
we'll see this worker
I'll just see if we can magnify that so
you can see that he's using that Tool uh
to really get in in ways that he
wouldn't be able to do now there is even
more advanced Tech on its way because 70
countries have offered assistance and
we've seen some of what they'll be
bringing this is from the Philippines uh
this is a vibroscope so it's got
um headphones here you've got this long
pole on that long pole has a camera on
the top it's extendable so you can feed
that through the rubble look for people
when you find them communicate them tell
them that help is on its way the Italian
firefighters originally Dirt 4 Chord
they posted this video you can see
that's another those Concrete Cutters
that we saw uh from earlier
um another big hydraulic chomping tool
there we've got this fan which is useful
so that will blow uh if you're stuck in
a confined space CO2 perhaps building up
this will help ventilator space or maybe
there's just other things to buy a bit
more time so there's a lot of Kit going
in we can see all of this is being
prepared that's actually the same sort
of shares we saw earlier in that video
from the white helmet but despite all
this kid which is going to be helpful
there's another bit that's going to be
just as helpful which is a lot less
high-tech but just really vital spoiled
the surprise there but
here you can see dogs sniffer dogs are
going to be a vital part of this effort
in terms of finding humans there's a lot
of tech we have other things which can
trap mobile phones for instance but
sniffer dogs really really important for
this effort and lots of those teams will
be arriving they'll be getting to those
zones as quickly as they put they can
because it is a vital period search and
rescue experts say that between one and
three days after disaster that is the
golden period for saving people now
Wednesday is day three so time is off
the essence